Good morning, everyone.
Hope everybody is having a good day. Happy August first.
Can't believe that it's already August.
I always wonder where the time goes, especially in the summer.
Remember when the kids were growing up in August was always the time to
hurry up and check everything off the list that we wanted to do during the summer
because it always seemed like June and July went so fast.
We didn't get around all those fun things until August.
Lots of fun memories from August.
All right, we are going to get started here.
A few questions came in again, just a reminder to submit the questions
through the membership site. Thank you guys for doing that.
Most of you on here are very familiar with the membership site.
You're utilizing it and you are sending in your questions.
So thank you. We appreciate you using that.
The first question that came in was regarding coffee enemas.
So she says, I'm having a hard time holding the coffee enemas.
Do you have any suggestions? Only able to hold it for a few minutes and then get cramps.
So yes, so certainly, you know, you don't have to use as much liquid.
You could try that and just using a smaller amount.
You know, we always say just, you know, do the best that you can.
If you're only able to hold it for a few minutes, that's fine.
I know the suggestion is to try to hold it for about 12 to 15 minutes.
So you get a few cyclings of.
Let's just add.
Here we go.
Okay. Sorry. Somebody joined.
And I had to let them in. Okay.
So coffee enemas. Okay. So yes, less, less liquid.
You can, you know, if you only can do it for a few minutes,
that's fine. The recommendation of 12 to 15 minutes is obviously in the kind of.
The proper way to do it, you get a few cyclings of the blood. Then, you know, through.
You get like every three or four minutes, I believe the blood is fully kind of like filtered throughout the body and through the liver.
And so by holding it on that amount of time, you're getting a few cyclings of that.
And if you cannot do that full amount of time, that's fine. Just do whatever you can.
You know, the longer you do coffee enemas, the more your body gets used to it,
and the more likely you will be to eventually, you know, hold it for that longer period of time.
But don't force anything.
So whatever you can do, but try less liquid.
And then also just a reminder on.
On our membership site, under the.
You can see these sources, sec resources tab at the top and then under detox, there is a.
Dr. Conner's put some information on an easy way to do the coffee enemas, kind of the lazy man's way.
And so there's.
You can take a look at that and maybe, you know, you try doing it the easy way for for a little while.
And then.
Try to hold it longer.
And then you can get it in for coffee enemma leave valve open so food can get pushed out.
When when there's gas, so that's a little tip, maybe that will help.
Alright, thank you for that.
Okay.
And then also, you know, there is tons of information on coffee enemas just on the regular blog as well.
Coffee enemas, you can find lots of information, lots of videos, so you might find something there that is helpful as well, but just do the best you can and give yourself grace.
Alright, while looking through looking at rife programs, we came across what has exactly described my knee trauma.
See the quote from rife program below that has it sent him to the ER.
So this has happened to him three times while doing a major detox for bladder cancer.
Do you think this is accurate.
My right kidney has historically been weaker.
So if so, should I be suspending the current programs you have me on.
And target kidney support until I can get past this hurdle.
And then there was a long description of the herxheimer reaction.
And I didn't copy and paste that and put that in here, but we kind of talked about this.
I think it was last week because you had sent in a question regarding this. And so, you know, we talked about your acid and gout and how certainly killing off things too quickly can cause a build up of your acid.
And Dr. Connors had mentioned in a previous.
A previous zoom call that he still wanted to do the.
Still wanted you to do the. Here we go.
Okay.
He still wanted you to do your cancer fighting programs and suggested maybe the ball moving it farther away.
So, you know, right or wrong answer here, we really just have to, you know, just play it by ear and experiment a little bit.
So typically when we're having a herxheimer reaction.
It's because we're killing pathogens.
And then what happens is in the process of killing those pathogens, they release another toxin within the body.
There's a toxin that is held within the membrane of certain pathogens that like Lyme disease.
And so when we kill those things, we're also destroying that membrane.
And then that toxin is released within the body. And so your body has to get rid of that toxin as well. So it's kind of like this double detoxification process that has to go on.
And if the body isn't able to do that quickly enough, we can have all of the symptoms of a herxheimer reaction, which are not fun.
It happens, like I said, when we're killing off a pathogen, something that's living, you know, you know, mold fungus parasite bacteria.
Mostly it's those gram negative bacteria that really throw us for a loop, which is why we have to go really slow when we're dealing with supporting our line patients.
That's the time we don't even start our line patients out on kill programs because we just have to go so slow and we start doing other things first, like reducing inflammation looking at brain support to reduce microglial priming or shift microglial priming into the state where we're not spewing those inflammatory chemicals.
So trying to shift it into more of an anti inflammatory state.
As far as this question in this specific scenario and bladder cancer fighting and the rife programs.
You can stop if you know I understand that this is extremely hard and painful and you know you had to start out on some of those prescriptions to manage what's going on.
And so, although we really want you to do the cancer fighting programs, maybe you do have to just suspend it for a little while and focus on other things to focus on anything, you know, inflammation related so any rife program for inflammation any supplements that are anti inflammatory anything.
And so, you know, you have to do a lot of things to support your kidneys, I know we talked about doing some lab work to see your kidney function, I think Dr. Conner just mentioned also doing a pass a line test possibly because it just seems like this extreme reaction you're having is more, you know, we see it more often with other things, not cancer.
For sure.
So more testing, but absolutely you can try stopping your nighttime programs and focus for a few days just on, like I said, inflammation, you know, kidney support and see if that makes a difference.
You feel better within a few days and you can slowly start your cancer programs, maybe you start off doing foot baths and not doing your nighttime program, so we just have to play with it and see see what we can do.
But certainly we agree we do need to get over this hurdle because it's not good to constantly have that pain and just the stress the stress alarm ringing in your body that is not good so.
Okay, another chat that came in let's see oh, I'll answer that in a second.
Sorry address here, okay.
All right, so there used to be a search feature or a feature to search video content on the site, I can no longer find it on the blog or the membership site help in my missing it.
I think you are maybe missing it because I know it is it is there and maybe I know that Dustin is adding so many things to the membership page and we're updating you know, just the general blog all the time so maybe whenever you are looking for some reason.
There i'm not quite sure, but certainly it's this little kind of magnifying glass thing I you know double checked and it is there for me today and so it's on the membership site here and then on the blog.
it's right here so upper right hand corner look for that magnifying glass, it should be there, hopefully it was just a fluky thing that it was not showing up for you at the time when you were looking for it, so it should be there.
Okay, I got the droppers for the CT and gadolinium the homeopathic droppers is what she's referring to is it okay to take all my droppers and sprays together one right after the other I also have the biopsy drops and the addicts so she's essentially got four homeopaths that she's taking.
Yes, you can take them all together they are different energies addressing different things so they are not going to cancel each other out the thing that you do want to be mindful of and i'm sure you are aware of this but for others who may not be aware when you're taking a homeopath.
Pathetic dropper you do want to make sure you are not taking it with around coffee around anything with mint flavor so you know the experiment in the greens first you would want to wait on any toothpaste so there are some strong.
Things like that that you want to keep your homeopathic droppers away from you know physically like don't brush your teeth and then just take the homeopathic dropper you want to wait about an hour from those things and and we do list them out.
You should have received a list of you know kind of how to take it and the things to stay away from one of them the directions say 30 minutes from food is this a minimum yes so at least 30 minutes away from food okay to have the homeopathic droppers hours from food yes that's fine empty stomach but at least 30 minutes away from food.
And then I assume I should start the CT and gadolinium droppers right after the procedures I wouldn't even start taking them before you can start taking them maybe a week before just to kind of prepare the body and then take them until the bottle is gone so just continue taking them it might take a month it might take.
A couple months and not quite sure how long each of those bottles will last but I would just continue to take them until those bottles are gone.
Okay I got an iron infusion today and I am scheduled for the next two Thursdays to get two more now i'm wondering if I should or should not take iron supplements while doing iron infusions I can't find any information on that so I.
So I you know I asked this person how she was feeling because depending on the severity of your anemia and what your symptoms are you might be feeling horrible not being able to move just sort a key no energy so all of those symptoms of being anemic and if you are severely anemic in that case then maybe you might want to continue the iron supplements because.
The infusions take a little time to work in this case I don't believe that this person is feeling that way due to the anemia and so I personally would not take the iron supplements and I would let the iron infusions do their work because.
You know my belief is that she's okay she's functioning she might not feel the greatest but she's not having the severe symptoms of anemia and so in an effort to you know keep this balance here because of you know kind of the conflict of interest between cancer and iron and.
Iron fueling cancer and just trying to strike that balance we don't want to be taking iron supplements if they're not if it's not necessary so I would not take the iron supplements if I was feeling okay and I could you know function and I would just let the iron infusions over the next three weeks do their job in raising my my iron level in the blood so if I was feeling horrible.
Horrible, then I maybe would continue taking iron supplements to just try to feel better so that I could obviously continue to work on cancer fighting and all of the things that we want the body to be doing when.
You know you know we're not in that period in that sympathetic state of fight or flight flight stress you know pain all of those things we want to get into that pair sympathetic branch so if you're managing everything then I would not take this supplements.
All right hello I submitted a question last week about each bot that's hyperbaric oxygen therapy sorry if repeating but it was not addressed on the zoom call.
I understand that each bot can be beneficial for oxygenating a cancer environment however is this always true for someone like me with veg F issues a triple negative breast cancer diagnosis.
And remaining her to positive tumor surrounded in vessels is there any risk to oxygenating an already highly vascular tumor or in any case is oxygenating the environment a good thing thank you.
So just a reminder that we do have two zoom calls now so I believe that I answered this question actually I know I answered this question last Monday we talked about that Jeff.
We talked about oxygen and how you know the VGEF so that's a tumor suppressor gene vascular and a failure growth factor and how.
If we've highlighted that on your tumor suppressor gene report then we want to eliminate things like kale that encourage a nitric oxide production so basically VGEF stimulates nitric oxide production and that can encourage blood vessel growth anywhere but we do you know including a tumor so we don't want to stimulate VGEF so we talked about that last week in the difference between.
And that and hyperbaric oxygen therapy which is just providing oxygen to the tissue it's not increasing.
VGEF so hyperbaric oxygen therapy is good to oxygenate the tissue and the environment surrounding a tumor.
tumors thrive and I help hypoxic or a low oxygen environment so anytime we're introducing something that can destabilize a tumor that is good and so hyperbaric is good.
So again, I reminder that there's two zoom calls so if you prefer that your question be answered on a specific zoom call Monday or Wednesday just indicate that when you're submitting your question.
I know we're just kind of getting used to having two zoom calls so you know if you're only available on the Wednesday night you can't you know because you're working midday and you can't get on the Monday call then certainly you know just put in your zoom question form that you would like it to be answered on the Wednesday zoom call because that's the one you'll be on.
Or certainly if you want Dr Connors to answer your question no hard feelings whatsoever completely understand that if you would prefer Dr Connors to answer that question just right in there you know for Dr Connors Wednesday zoom call.
Otherwise if there's not a specific person or time zoom call indicated we are just going to answer them as they come in so her question.
I did answer last week on the Monday zoom call but she wasn't on it so she didn't hear the answer and was waiting for it to be answered on Wednesday by Dr Connors so just a little reminder.
That there are two we're just answering them in the order that they come in unless you've indicated on your form that you would like either myself or Dr Connors to answer you know or Monday or Wednesday so.
All right, and then this is also the reminders based off of that last question that the recordings of my calls and Dr Connors calls are always available on a membership site usually within minutes.
Of the end of the zoom call so there are two different tabs so a tab for Dr Connors zoom calls and then it's just a playlist and so you can list the most current one is kind of loaded and ready to go and then you know if you were to continue listening it would just.
Play the one that was from the previous week and it would just keep playing them same with mine obviously there's not as many for me since i've only been doing this for about a month now so I believe this is the fourth one.
So, but you can click on my tab there and it will bring up all of my calls so if you feel like your question was missed it may again because it was answered on the zoom call that you are not on and so you can listen to the previous week's zoom call either mine or Dr Connors.
And then I just brought this up here there weren't a lot of questions that came in so I just was thinking oh maybe i'll throw in a few just kind of reminders the blog so just the general blog grace is doing such a great job just putting content up there lots of fun blog posts regarding recipes foods you know some interesting things but again there's the search function on the blog so.
So if you have questions in between zoom calls or you know you're just doing your own research on something search it up in the blog most likely there's an article video or some information on that that can help you and you know if you have specific questions then submit it to the zoom call but certainly some general questions or general information search out the blog and you know visit it it frequently there's like I said.
Lots of new information and content being posted weekly if not daily and there's a lot of new fun things that Grace is putting up there so check that out.
And then somebody had sent in some photos of their tumors to me this morning and so I just wanted to remind people that if you have a tumor that is visible.
To you know the eyes are is changing in some way please do send us photos because you know with working from a distance it's it's not always easy it's a little more difficult to really grasp and understand what you guys are dealing with pictures do.
Help and they're also a way to track to see changes so if you do have a tumor that is visible please do send us photos if you send them to this email address info at Conner's clinic dot com they will go directly to doctor Conner's certainly you can email them to me if you'd like and I forward them.
Or upload them into your file and ask doctor Conners to take a look so we can kind of check those out monitor give feedback but if you prefer to go directly to doctor Conner's info at Conner's clinic dot com is the email address and.
Okay let's see if I can find the chat here to see if anybody had any questions okay so somebody asked excuse me when filling out the HIPAA release and listing the clinic what address should I use so our summer set clinic address is on Revard street.
And let me see if I can pull it up here quick.
So you would use that one so let's see if I can bring it up here.
I'm on my laptop so I don't have my normal tabs Revard street summer set Wisconsin okay let me it's not bringing it up let me see here sorry yeah yeah.
Clearly this is not at my fingertips here on this computer.
Okay, I won't spend any more time looking.
um Revard street summer set Wisconsin I want to say the address is 830 Revard street um but send me an email and I can get it to you I apologize off the top of my head I don't know the address okay any other questions for me today.
Yeah that yeah that that was it for questions so hopefully you know kind of as we as we progress we'll get some more questions that come in I know summertime is usually busy people are busy enjoying the outdoors and so we are a little slower with zoom calls and questions during the summer.
But anybody else have any questions anybody want to just chat in the most amazing thing they did this weekend so we can see some some fun things trying to think of what I did that was the most fun this weekend.
Yard work nothing nothing super exciting which is good getting my daughter ready to.
Head back to Duluth for her last year of college ooh somebody took a foraging class that sounds interesting have to give us some tips on what you learned anyone else family time that's great that's awesome yeah we hope to get a few more weekends in up at the cabin my.
Parents have a cabin in Spooner Wisconsin so we've been going to Spooner for you know almost my entire life so.
Great family times and we haven't been up the last handful of weekends so we hope to get a few more weekends in right any other questions alright everyone I guess we'll wrap it up so it was just a short zoom call today.
But some good questions so it makes again for sending those in just a reminder membership page here here's the address up there so frequent that for lots of information and again we're updating it pretty regularly with more stuff so.
Alright everybody have a wonderful rest of your day and we will talk again on Monday next Monday bye bye.
Oh wait maybe somebody had a chat oh just a thank you you are so very welcome.
Bye bye.